[Música]
Bienvenidos a exclusivo de France 24 soy
juin Muñoz y en esta edición conversamos
con José Mújica
expresidente Uruguay y una de las
figuras más relevantes de la izquierda
latinoamericana a sus 87 años está
retirado de la política institucional
Pero sigue muy atento a la actualidad
internacional Muchas gracias por estar
en la entrevista de France 24 Pepe Bueno
es un gusto poderlos saludar a la
distancia
de este Rinconcito del Sur que también
existe
Pepe en esta guerra en esta devaluación
de las monedas e inflación de pues la
crisis climática también en plena post
pandemia Qué siente preocupación o
esperanza
la esperanza es una cuestión biológica
el amor
del amor a la vida que tenemos ahora
desde el punto de vista racional
tenemos otra preocupación
el peligro latente de desembocar en una
guerra catastrófica
El desafío ecológico de la gran pregunta
caminamos
hacia un holocausto ecológico
tan alegre inconscientemente
son todas preocupaciones
de este mundo que se ha apretado y se ha
achicado
que tiene más recursos que nunca
y por lo tanto tiene mucho más
responsabilidad
la política en el sentido trascendente
lo que está fallando es la política
estamos como bien dice en plena
reordenación geopolítica del mundo y
Rusia ha sido un referente histórico en
el contrapeso contra occidente para
cierta izquierda latinoamericana cuál
cree que debe ser su posición en el
conflicto actual
eso que tú dices es relativo
porque de gol por ejemplo pensaba que
Europa ha llegado a los urales
la cosa es compleja
Lo que pasa que el mundo no es solo
Europa
tiene la responsabilidad de haber
probijado el tipo de civilización que
tenemos hoy
pero tampoco parece que Europa está a la
de la propia civilización que ha
desatado
debió de anticiparse
en la política de la otan que a la corta
o a la larga el oso ruso iba a tirar un
zarpazo
Por qué Porque la historia
la historia algo nos tiene que iluminar
no se puede acorralar a una potencia así
como así y
hubo síntomas de aviso
pasó Exactamente lo contrario
de aquella crisis
que hizo en la época de Nikita cruzó
Kennedy
donde funcionó la política
vía telefónica
y cada cual hizo lo que tenía que hacer
y la humanidad salió de un susto ahora
pasó Exactamente lo contrario y estamos
Enredados
pagando un costo de carácter fenomenal
nada de esto lo digo para justificar la
barbarie de Putin pero la barbarie es
mutua
es un mal cierre de la Guerra Fría
Pero bueno ahora ahora tenemos ya las
consecuencias y tenemos que que
apechugarla
estas consecuencias se han notado en
América Latina obviamente y usted en su
momento coincidió como presidente con
Hugo Chávez también compartió con Fidel
Castro pero ahora en América Latina
están Gustavo Petro Gabriel borich Luis
Arce esta nueva izquierda
latinoamericana ha aceptado El marco que
impone el sistema capitalista
creo que es una cuestión de etapa
nosotros tenemos el problema
la historia demostró que los intentos de
apalancar la construcción de una
sociedad socialista
por las vías que se ensalaron
la historia demostró que no era posible
y como dijo Palmer alguna vez esa es la
vía más larga el capitalismo
y hoy nos damos cuenta
que tenemos que poner el hombro para
intentar lograr
equilibrar siquiera en parte el
desarrollo hay un desbalance mundial
enorme
y nuestra primera preocupación tiene que
ser esa y no poner la carreta delante de
los bueyes más claro No creo que se
pueda soñar con la creación de una
sociedad mejor
dejando
la libertad por el camino
y
y la cooperación humana como como como
factor de de Progreso
el socialismo no puede pelearse con la
libertad
no puede pelearse con el mercado
y tiene que pelearse En todo caso con el
egoísmo
tenemos una óptica
distinta tenemos que aprender del pasado
y
nos sigue doliendo la enorme desigualdad
de la sociedad de contemporánea
sobre todo desigualdad en el reparto
Y en este marco en el que estamos que
haría usted o que cree usted que es la
solución para mejorar la vida de las
personas
tenemos que capitalizarnos ser menos
bobo invertir más
y apuntalar la experiencia del
autogestión de la participación social
Pero nunca pelearnos con el mercado
si si hay que superarlo habrá que
superarlo con el tiempo y probablemente
las sociedades necesiten una una
confluencia
de por un lado lo social y por otro lado
la iniciativa porque lo que hay que
priorizar es el desarrollo de la vida
y creo que es todo un proceso
Porque además estamos entrando en un
cambio civilizatorio ahora Necesitamos
recursos para educar y formar a nuestra
gente ante Este cambio civilizatorio que
está basado
en el uso y abuso del conocimiento
si permanecemos
sin invertir una fortuna en la cabeza de
nuestros muchachos no es que nos vayamos
a llegar al socialismo no vamos a llegar
ni ni a un capitalismo medianamente
decente vamos a quedar en el pelotón de
los irrelevantes por lo tanto
la prioridad de esta etapa histórica es
desarrollarnos
usted fue guerrillero tupamaro y décadas
después de un discurso ante la ONU en la
que dijo quién tuviera la fuerza de
cuando éramos capaces de albergar tanta
utopía la revolución socialista con la
que soñaba ya es imposible
yo no sé si la revolución socialista
Será posible
lo que tengo Claro hoy
que nunca lo va a ser a partir de una
sociedad su desarrollada y más que
Revolución
es un salto y es la conformación de una
cultura distinta
porque mi generación
[Música]
pensó que cambiaba el mundo cambiando
las relaciones de producción y
distribución y no me dio
el papel que cumple la cultura
y si no cambia la cultura sino cambia la
cabeza en el fondo No cambia nada
Ese fue el error soviético y etcétera
etcétera
entonces mientras curamos los mismos
valores
podrá evolucionar la la riqueza de la
economía Pero no evolucionamos nosotros
en materia de valores
en esas luchas Guerrilleras de los años
60 y 70 se fundamentaron en lo que el
Che llamó el hombre nuevo ahora cree que
se ha llegado a ese hombre nuevo a un
hombre mejor a un hombre peor
no de nuevo no tiene nada sigue siendo
profundamente egoísta
demasiado
enamorado del dinero
y y del poder
tiene muchas virtudes también nos ha
deparado unos 30 o 40 años más de vida
de promedio lo cual no es poca cosa nos
ha aportado muchísimo también
si cada persona para bañarse
precisa 200 250 litros
estos siete mil millones que somos
nos vamos a quedar sin agua necesitamos
una civilización un poco más racional
menos depredadora porque recursos hay
para todo pero no se puede despilfarrar
como estamos en
ese es el problema que tenemos hoy todo
tiene límites en el mundo que nos toca
vivir
usted siempre quiso huir del reformismo
lo consiguió durante su presidencia
no en absoluto
vivimos la vida es reformarse lo único
que existe permanentemente en el
transcurso de la vida es el cambio es
y aquella vieja ley de heráclito el agua
que viviste pasarnos la volverás a ver
si nosotros nos quedamos anquilosados a
lo largo de los años pensando lo mismo
cuando la realidad fluyente nos va
enseñando otras cosas no aprendemos nada
mi papel hoy
es luchar para que las nuevas
generaciones
cometan los errores de su tiempo no los
nuestros
precisamente usted tuvo que ingresar en
prisión y pasó un total de 15 años al
salir dijo que ningún luchador social
puede desechar definitivamente la lucha
armada en ningún momento de su vida lo
mantiene
todo depende de las condiciones Si se te
viene encima una dictadura y te persigue
que te pones a rezar padre nuestro pero
espero espero que esas circunstancias no
se
hace 20 años también en el libro
Charlando con Pepe Mujica dijo que todo
lo que vive tiende a hacerse conservador
y también la izquierda es Mújica más
conservador hoy
sí naturalmente lo soy
conservador para ganar aliento
aprendiendo de los golpes del pasado
pero con una cosa muy clara
yo no traicioné a pesar de mis carnes
que llevo adentro del punto de vista
esencial
creo que el capitalismo en la economía
de Mercado Le trajeron mucho la
humanidad pero la humanidad tendrá que
intentar superarlo porque si no las
contradicciones
que genera la lucha por el éxito
económico
amenazan con transformar esta tierra en
una gigantesca tumba de la especie
normalmente los referentes Siempre han
sido de norte a sur y usted consiguió
romper ese eje
bueno el sur también existe
al fin al cabo el norte al mal desastre
y en el sur pagamos el costo Porque el
cambio climático es muy probable que nos
afecte mucho más en el sur que pero
estamos navegando en el mismo barco y
ahora tenemos responsabilidad colectiva
tengo
tengo mi reproche con Europa
porque
muchos de los latinoamericanos somos
descendientes de gente que vino en los
barcos tenemos una matriz cultural
bastante Mediterráneo
y hace muchos años esta parte del mundo
veinte años que negocia por un acuerdo
más o menos con Europa
y resulta inútil
[Música]
Y entonces
la presencia china cada vez más fuerte
en esta región es más compradora
y empiezan a quejarse en Europa en
Estados Unidos
pero son puras queja y reproche
pero en el fondo nos cerraron la puerta
para seguir integrados en ese mundo y
tenemos que aprender a vivir como
podemos
Europa tiene que hacerse cargo también
de sus errores
me gustaría continuar hablando sobre
esto y muchas más preguntas me queda una
última José tiene 87 años y pasó 15 en
prisión siente que todavía la vida tiene
que devolverle esos años
no
la vida es hermosa
con toda su penalidades
y en esos años
siete años que tuve sin leer
y otros tantos donde apenas podía leer
física y química
curiosamente son los años donde aprendí
más
y por eso por eso vamos la vida tal vez
se aprende más del dolor que de la
Bonanza
Y sabes querido lo que es triunfar en la
vida
levantarse y Volver a empezar cada vez
que uno cae en todo los órdenes de la
existencia
en el fondo
hay que afirmar el sentido de la vida y
gracias por tu espacio y un abrazo a la
distancia Muchas gracias Pepe por estar
en France 24 ha sido un verdadero placer
y muchas gracias También a nuestra
audiencia Pueden seguir más contenidos
como este en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]